okay so the boys are off to go do the
big scary roller coasters yeah and
Catherine and I are gonna go do
something way more fun all right we got
all wet oh yeah
good morning today is day two in
Universal today turn right to Vineland
Road
day three that were in Orlando
it's supposed to rain all day for the
next few days
it's okay we need it for this month
we need the we need the wet for this hot
weather
let's go
[Music]
I'm ready
we're arriving The Adventure Island
we got a little early 15 minutes already
I think they already let people in at 8
30. so now we're gonna head to the
Harvard ride the Harry Harker ride let's
go
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I'm Ron that's only the entrance
though
we go walk in there's another another
line yeah oh that sucks no it's okay
I'll be fine
thank you
so I can't go in because uh Evan has a
little pouch and then I have a purse
um so I told her you know what they
could sit in
um I'll just then I'll just sit outside
and wait for them but in the meantime
I'm gonna get a coffee for Evan and I
and I'm gonna get some water for the
kids my kids liked it
we're going to
try I'm gonna stay out because Catherine
would be scared
she's already scared from the last one
[Music]
thank you
the boys are done Evan and Catherine are
going to Dr Seuss Jeffrey and Hayden are
going to philosopher
roller coaster
just tell yourself I'm fine I'll be fine
Hayden okay so the boys are off to go do
the big scary roller coasters yeah and
Catherine and I are gonna go do
something way more fun right Dr Seuss
let's go here we are going to Seuss's
Landing all the fun rides for 12 and
under baby 12 and under that's where
it's at
so that's where it's at
we are excited
excited Catherine
oh yeah
[Music]
okay next up is the carousel
look at that you ready Catherine
this is us this is my guy all right yeah
one foot in and up hey you did it all
right this guy I mean let's go we are
ready to do this we are ready look at
this me and this guy now wait wait wait
there he is there he is you ready
Captain yeah you ready what's yours name
what's the name of yours Lovely Bubbly
woohoo
[Music]
how was it Hayden no too scared you
almost pass out
good thing you have water did you pee
pgp maybe a little bit the drip
Jeffrey you like it yeah good let's go
next one we're going to the river of
Adventure they are ready it's in a hot
day I can't see Hayden you ready to go
Hayden
no sure no okay let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we had a good lunch
he got the same thing I got ripped rips
ribs ribs and chicken Jeffrey got ribs
and chicken too it was good it was
filling I thought it would be I thought
it would not be as feeling so I ordered
one for myself and I was so full
yeah anyways we're back to
[Music]
you
we're back to the water of Adventure
fingers crossed hope nothing gets run
right now
[Music]
what's that fun yeah yeah good thing
good thing that we'll go back we went
back yes yeah you like it Jeffrey
yeah good our next ride we're gonna go
to the King Khan
King Khan are you ready to see some King
Khan yeah yeah
so how come you're soaked
I was uh so there's a okay I mean no
offense yeah and then I stand there yeah
and then the boat just like went
crashing down yeah
it's good on a hot day like like this
right I like it okay let's go
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how was your ride I got stepped on
my 13 year old kid and my toe was
hurting but it was a good ride all right
next ride we're going to
um basically we're going to get all wet
that's it I'll show you to you
[Music]
all right we got all wet oh yeah no way
I was I was on collecting Shield Jeffrey
got the awards and and Hayden was weird
together you guys are the worst yeah you
guys got the most water first I I was
pretty bad too my shoes I could feel the
water in my shoes
anyway so have fun kids kids have fun
next round we're gonna go to I think
we're gonna go to the Spiderman ride
let's go
[Music]
how do you like that right Evan good
yeah last one last one for you for me
yeah Evan and uh Hayden and Catherine
they're gonna go get dessert Jeffrey and
I we're gonna go on to the hawk roller
coaster
Jeffrey is very excited about this I
don't know I haven't gone on a roller
coaster for a long time all right bad
news we were all ready to go and then uh
they say it's closed due to lightning
lightning lightning I heard lightning
but lightning lightning sadness
all right well we'll go get join them
for dessert
this is my drink
my dessert drink all right then what did
you get
got a wand what kind of one
Baltimore nice nice are you gonna try it
on I am but I have butter beer over here
I'll try it on the car okay it started
to rain
coming down gonna come to Heart All
right we made it to the car
it was raining just before we
um about to leave the Park yeah we're
gonna go watch it we're gonna go pick up
some
stuff and then go make some dinner
okay yeah healthy healthy yeah healthy
dinner hey nice
[Music]
after we came home I went to grocery get
some food you did a great job and then
um came home made some food I made
burger for the kids vegetables were good
too yes some vegetables probably was
great yeah I I actually I didn't even
eat a burger I only have vegetables yeah
the veggies felt good to have some
veggies yeah I had a whole bag of mini
carrots too oh really yeah yeah I give
you a lot more vegetables and I gave
myself a lot like a vegetables get some
yeah they have and then we watch a show
stranger things yeah season two yeah
getting started behind we'll catch you
now yeah so tell the kids to relax for a
bit and then go to bed and then because
we have a birdie date again tomorrow
tomorrow we are off to Disney for the
first day Magic Kingdom our first day of
two days at the Magic Kingdom and if you
want to see the amazingness that happens
there check the video right there next
to us continue to believe and we'll see
you there